first of all Tony let me give the full
introduction a guy who one day will be
in the Hall of Fame if I have any say in
this and the former Jags offensive
lineman analyst for Thursday Night
Football and Westwood One joining us on
the program how are you feeling
good and before I talk about this Corona
wasn't Kareem abdul-jabbar and Bill
Walton both better than Michael Jordan
in college yes yeah I just wanna make
sure I thought so - thank you - anyways
the I'm doing better every day and get
my strength back my lungs are still a
little bit shady in the sense of it can
I don't gas where I'm not gasping for
air I can breathe everything but I get
tired quickly so that's probably gonna
be the last thing comes back when did
you realize something was wrong so
probably March 17 you know the night of
the 16th but really the 17th I started
getting like I felt like a head cold and
I honestly thought was just malar geez
no big deal took my temperature just
because this co good thing going on
making sure you know I did have a fever
anything I didn't I woke up Wednesday
morning and I felt pretty lousy and so
like the flu almost and I took my
temperature had a fever and then I
started thinking okay this is
interesting and about an hour later I
got a phone call from a friend of mine
say eh
last Thursday we were around somebody
who has tested positive sense and so I
took a test went to Mayo my doctor Mayo
took a test and found out the next
Friday I think was product 18th whatever
19th of March that I was positive and
and then the kind of the journey began
at that point what did you do next you
know I'll be honest then I didn't think
much of it both my wife and I were
positive because we were at the same
event
she felt fine I felt like I had the flu
and I said you know I'm 47
you know I'm healthy I've no underlying
you know health conditions I'll be fine
I figured by Sunday I'd be up and go and
actually talk to a buddy of mine who had
been exposed as well and ended up not
having any issues and I go we said
that's will
Sunday we'll be able to you know hook up
and you know we'll get together just one
of our houses and and by Sunday night I
was you know I thought I'd feel a little
bit better but then come about Monday
night Tuesday the funk you know I really
started going downhill fast and ended up
on the hospital on that Wednesday when
did you realize when you're in the
hospital that this is really serious not
I don't know if you felt it was
life-threatening but did you feel like
it was yeah
and so I woke up that Wednesday morning
and knew that something was not right
and the legs going bad because I was
wheezing and I was having a harder time
to catch my breath and so I called the
doc he said hey go to the emergency room
and I'll be honest when I went to the
burden see room I thought I was just
going to get some fluids and some bets
and I'd be back home in fact my daughter
dropped me off when I told her I said
I'll call you to come pick me up when
I'm done and I went in there and they
took x-rays of my chest and the
pulmonologist came in and said hey
listen we put you in ICU I think at that
point I was like well wait a second I
see you and I said actually Mike
responsible says I don't want to go and
he says well you need to be on oxygen
you need to be watched very closely and
we need to get these drugs in you and
that's when it got you know real like
this is you know this could go either
way and the doctor basically said like
we don't know where this is going to go
or do our best it wasn't like you know
your typical doctor visit where he said
hey we got this everything to be fine
you'll be okay it was we're going to see
where this goes we're going to give you
drugs when do everything we can we're
going to get you on oxygen and there
were moments in the ICU and I'm laying
there and I'm thinking you know is
that's it you know is this the way you
go and it was it was some scary moments
because you by yourself your family
can't come see ya the only people
allowed in the room or the medical
healthcare workers who are amazing
people are coming in they're all their
protective outfits and everything else
but other than that you're by yourself
so there were some moments were you
questioned and because you don't know
which way it's going to go thankfully
day three in the ICU I started heading
in the right direction
action and got better pretty quick from
that point on and that loneliness that
isolation and this is what I have a
person who friend who works in ER in a
Houston hospital and they said you can
just see the panic in the patients
because they don't know and we don't
know either and you're just lone you're
you're there with your thoughts there
and that guy you know that can you know
you does damage to your psyche because
then you're your own worst enemy yeah
and I think the two things he said one
is you by yourself when your mind starts
running and then to these health care
workers are amazing but they're also
honest I mean they don't sit there and
say everything's fine I mean they came
in and said we're gonna do everything we
can but we got to see where this goes we
just don't know yet and those things put
together are really scary or not and and
this is where you know I'm thankful for
my faith you know you really because I
give nowhere I didn't know where else to
turn I'd North Saturn and and you just
pray you hope you know the other people
out there who love you are praying for
you and that's where I tried to focus on
because there was moments I could feel
my mind starting to run away in the
wrong direction you feel the anxiety
come in and and you just the way I
thought it was knowing that my family
was praying for me and then know my
faith in God and and you just at that
point are believing and hoping for the
best and that's all you can do
he's Tony Boselli former Jags offensive
lineman five-time Pro Bowler and late
analyst Thursday Night Football in
Westwood one and then you start to think
not to put thoughts in your mind but you
hear other people who have been in this
situation they say is this how I'm going
to die like am I am I gonna die right
here I'm gonna be alone in a bed and my
daughter my wife are not gonna be around
is this the way I go no you're not
putting thoughts in my head because that
thought went to my head multiple times
playing in the ICU and like I just
couldn't I couldn't imagine it like this
can't be add there's no way well plus
the football mentality and use like you
fight you just fight at that point what
were you in denial at any point where
you go you know hey I'm Tony bacilli
this this doesn't hurt me I wasn't
this doesn't hurt me because it it was
hurting me and I was down and out but I
just I was just hurt you know you just
at that point I was really trusting in
my faith in the medical workers dan I'll
be honest that these doctors were the
best and I was at a great Hospital Mayo
they were caring for me that nurses we
were amazing
and I was just like this is gonna work
and you just have to believe because you
talk I think because the other thought
of it the other side of that and I I
thought not to go down that path is I'm
not going to make it I'm gonna die here
by ourselves and the scary the add to
the scariness is you know that there's
people down the hall that are dying yeah
that are in the ICU with you that are
dying and you're laying there and just
saying I gotta just keep fighting I got
to keep on believing and just hope that
what the doctors are doing is gonna work
I appreciate you telling this story
because I'm sure when this first broke
and somebody leaked that you had tested
positive you know there's this invasion
of privacy that you feel but we need
unfortunately we need faces and voices
and names attached to this just so we
get people's attention but if you were
going to do a PSA for this audience just
to let them know what this is and what
to do what would you say
yeah I'd say this is it's real this is
not you know listen people aren't
overdramatizing this this is a real like
virus that will mess you up if you get
it now the odds are that if you're my
age or younger or even a little bit
older and you're healthy that
yeah the odds are you're going to be
okay and it'll be a minor cold or flu
and you'll never even go to law school
but there's a chance you're going to
like me and chance even you're gonna
have worse than me and if you want to
roll those world of dice on your own
life that's your business
but now is a time to think about other
people because there are elderly there's
people with underlying medical
conditions compromised immune systems
that can't fight this and we need to be
thinking about everybody else right now
and it's difficult because people are
losing jobs
that is awful and that's where we got to
listen to these medical be health care
experts and hopefully we can get through
this
over the next month we can get to their
side and start getting trying to get
back to some normal life activity but if
we don't take this serious it's not just
you here I worry but I think we have to
worry about our neighbors and the people
around us I think it's really a time we
need to think of not just ourselves but
everyone else around us how's your wife
doing she's great she's way too uh
further than I am she never even got a
fever
you know she's you know she lost her
taste and smell that was her big thing
and she was tired and she you know she
she looks at me like I'm soft because
she just said she looked at the virus
and just said get out of here and Here I
am I see the cup football players that's
it that's the crazy thing dan you don't
know how it's going to affect you you
know two people got out at the same
place we were together one Bowl xlvii
both healthy no issues she has a mild
comes through it no issues I'm gasping
for air haven't gonna go that ICU I mean
so you just don't know and this is why
we have to take it really serious
seriously until the healthcare experts
start learning more about this and start
figuring things out and I'm worried
about and look there's other things to
worry about but it sports wise I'm
worried about this draft it feels like
we're trying to shoehorn this into
regularly scheduled programming and
let's continue to do this where I don't
know what the world is going to be like
or our country is going to be like in
seven days or 10 days should we be
holding the draft when we have it
scheduled yeah I don't have to answer
that then I mean I'll be honest you
haven't been paying much attention to
sports I'm just trying to get caught up
right now I think overall I think what
the NFL is trying to do is trying to
plan for like we're gonna play football
in September and I understand why
because you I mean at some point I mean
we have to worry about this disease but
I also worry about the people out of
work and the people that are trying to
you know provide for their families and
I think all of us we don't know what the
future holds
and I think trying to keep things as
normal as possible when we do the social
distancing I
that but also at the same time I think
we have to be flexible because like you
said it could change quickly and if it
changes quickly and it goes the wrong
direction I think and I hope leadership
will make the right decision because we
just don't know where this thing is
going we don't know what next week
simply like and for sure don't know what
it's going to be like in August and
September once again thank you for
telling your story I sure that it
probably was difficult the beginning to
share that but you know these are the
things that help get people aware and
maybe save lives as well so Dan you're
right and I was always you know I didn't
know when I was going to do this and I
was feeling so lousy I wanted to wait
and you mentioned that got leaked and
which was I was really disappointed
about because people I loved found out
about it without me telling them and
that bothered me but I after the first
time I did interview either my doctor at
Mayo he's overseen me and making sure I
get packed under percent and she said
hey listen I really want to thank you
and I said why and she says you don't
know what it means to us as healthcare
workers someone telling people and it's
not us to him but it's you telling them
really how serious this is because we
want people to take it serious and so at
that point I said you know what I'll
talk as much as I can and if it's going
to help health care workers it's going
to help people have awareness until we
get to their side of this it's a small
thing but at least I can try to do did
you wear your Jags Jersey to the
hospital did you look for special
treatment owning the people at male were
amazing and this is what blew me away
I mean you in the midst of all this
stuff that's going on you're you know
and you have conversations with God like
where are you and what's going on I
don't get this and but you see the love
of God and people in these health care
workers and what they do is amazing Dan
they come in knowing that this is a
watching people die from a virus and
without hesitation they came in and took
care of me and everyone else up there
and this is my only contact you
of people and they were amazing from the
doctors the PAS the nurses health tax
coming in to take my blood I mean they
were amazing people and I cannot say
what they mean to me and the courage
they showed to help me get through this
whole thing well it's good to talk to
you and we'll talk football
the next time let's hope so let's hope
we get back to some normal activities
when you talk sports here without
worrying about this in the near future
thank you Tony
good to talk to you thank you that's
Tony Boselli former Jags all-pro